I'm sorry Hunter guys aren't normally
this late sometimes they're a little bit
late but they're never like this late I
don't know I just I I got better [ __ ] to
do with my time honestly I
it's just taking forever hey
let's beat them up do it maybe they're
in the middle of
it okay well maybe maybe a courtesy text
or I don't know let's [ __ ] do it
Candace beam up Noah
yeah I'm the waste called do I oh there
he is what was that what'd you say
what's up what were you just saying what
were you saying what time were we
supposed to record
like we've been supposed to be recording
for 20 minutes now
oh did you say I'm a race car driver nah
no I was I was saying that what was that
voice you're using
it's it's just like a little it's online
gaming you wouldn't get it all right
let's get Cody up as well yeah can you
put me back down no we're gonna leave
you here we need to record the episode
Candace can we beam up Cody
yo what the [ __ ] what are you doing bro
nothing
I was just
what's why did you have a lobster
I was just putting them down
yeah it looks like it dude what are
those gloves it's my they're my Lobster
gloves
okay
it's my new pet
why is he all taped up
what were you gonna do with him
just
kiss him oh okay
okay
should we get started
yeah let's go let's just get started
okay he's just gonna hang right there
yeah I'll probably just chill
okay we should probably put them back in
the water
yeah yeah did you have water
yep
okay
have a good show guys thanks dude
foreign
what are you planning on doing to fix
your back I don't know is that just a
can of lobster water
I juice the lobster
for the record the lobster is still
alive it's gonna die soon yeah it will
die soon I thought there was going to be
some like Merit or some like positivity
to the end of the day but no they're
like no I'm just gonna give it to our
friend he's gonna cook it I felt bad I
mean that's what happens with lobsters
well it's true I don't know I'm like I'm
like the consumer grade cannibal right
where it's like I like my stuff in a
package I don't have to see its face or
anything it's fine right side so I don't
like killing animals you said it I said
it my dad made me go hunting with them a
while back
and I uh it was just I hated it did he
make you kill something he used my
shoulder as a stabilizer for his gun so
you can watch
I was his scope basically and I was like
no
was it
was it a Barrett 50 cal yeah yeah so not
safe dude
as soon as he shot it he's like got it
like called it like a three three like a
[ __ ] three-pointer he's like Kobe hit
that oh he's like got it like that
remember my ear was ringing I was like
my ear right here he's like stop he's
like good kill son oh no that one's
yours he was like you'd never be able to
shoot that the blood is on your hands no
no no he's like you'd never build one
he's like we're eating tonight because
of me and I'm like oh dude
this fool just puts a [ __ ] an
elephant rifle on yourself to kill a
deer he's like get down and you're just
on your knees
the deer just [ __ ] disintegrates in
front of me I'm like no and then he
stands up and pushes you behind the neck
into the ground yeah he's like you'd
never hit that tree stand boom yeah the
tree stand I break my arm too I'm like
my ear my arm Bambi yeah no Bambi yes
evaporates in front of you whoa
no I uh that was that was a very
traumatic experience there's one time we
were turkey hunting too and uh he went
out there with a chain gun
he's like loading me up
we were sitting there laying against the
trees sorry you never really hit this
it kills the whole Forest lays it all
the waste I'm like I bet I could have
hit something he's like doubt it now we
we were I had been purposely missing all
day because turkeys are just like the
easiest thing to kill because they're so
fat and stupid they're just we were
sitting there between a tree and I
remember working I remember being like
oh thank God we haven't killed anything
today and this possum walks right
between my dad and the trees no he just
does it and Possum's like hiss it's very
odd like a cat yeah he looks at me it's
just like
like that my dad's like you [ __ ]
right right by me Point Blank right by
me the blood gets all over my leg and
I'm like oh oh no and he's like he's
like God damn it be quiet he's like just
think about all the turkey and probably
just scare it off I'm like you just shot
your God
I don't react to [ __ ] them all little
round Hunter I just shot your gun you
shot your dad your gun Papa shut up shut
the hell up nobody hisses at my son but
me
last time that little son of a [ __ ] is
ever again
yeah I used to always yeah I used to
always think I was like doing like
I guess force Justice I guess we call it
by like purposely missing just like
shooting way above it and being like I
guess I missed it my dad would just
immediately shoot after me like it's
like I know you're gonna miss grab your
arms from behind pointed at it yeah
shoot it like uh there you go like a guy
trying to show a girl how to like golf
or something yeah yeah he's like behind
me holding my arms like that he's like
no squeeze your finger I don't want to
squeeze it then so fill up all the
tracker
he's using his nose to push your eye
into the into the iron sight get on him
get him get it on there there you go
watch it watch it die yeah
[Laughter]
that's my son God damn dude how often
did you go hunting I went like three
times when I remember calling my mom be
like I'm not doing this again I don't
want to go my dad's just like god dude
yeah we're raising a [ __ ] and then what
I did was I gained a bunch of weight as
a kid that's why I did it and I was like
I can't climb in the trees anymore dad
no not really but I just remember being
like I'm not going he's like I don't
care he just just like would go and your
name is Hunter that's a good point
that's a bit of a bummer isn't it yeah
dude dude your dad's [ __ ] thinking
he's like
I'm a name him Hunter I'm a reason to be
a goddamn quickest buckshot
in all of Kansas City and then no no
actually my dad wanted to name me Gus
why Gus
I have no idea and I and my mom was like
why don't we just do Hunter and he's
like all right but I just remember
thinking like I just I I had always been
like because in there for a while for
like I think I'm not even joking three
years he called me Gus after I stopped
hunting
literally
I was like I was like my name is
actually Hunter this is my legal name
actually
he's like what do we say Gus Gus short
for Goosey God damn dude that's
daddy Ron's a [ __ ] Daddy what that's
[ __ ] high grade bullying right there
oh yeah what are we having for breakfast
I don't know Gus what do you want to eat
maybe a plant and I just Cheerios yeah
let's have some salad yeah for the years
to come I should have just kept getting
more and more cute with it though you're
silly Daddy
right wouldn't that make it gross yeah
definitely you're so silly yeah yeah my
daddy's so silly he makes jokes yeah
he's got little pet names for me
yeah Social Services comes over
immediately we will have questions
you should talk to my silly daddy he's
got so many my daddy's silly
we wrestle all the time laughs